we're we're interested in the concept of
emergence so emergence is where
functions emerge that are not evident in
individual parts so if we think about
emergence in biological systems the
classical swarms of birds flying or fish
schooling no one really understands how
those individual entities coordinate
their actions but this has huge
implications also for medicine so how do
cells turn into tissues tissues organs
and organs organisms and in fact what's
really exciting about the CFR program
that that is unusual and unique across
the world is we're also looking at how
one can engineer these systems so this
has implications for autonomous vehicles
so now you know we're envisioning a
future state where a number of different
autonomous vehicles interact with each
other and we want to avoid unexpected
consequences of that interaction as well
as control and optimize their function
and we think there's really no cells
individual organisms and now individual
machines especially when those machines
are started to be endowed with
autonomous properties such as happens
with AI and other systems we think that
the the the opportunity of active
understanding human machine interfaces
from a cellular transplantation
perspective right through to prosthetics
and and finally humans interacting with
autonomous vehicles all depend upon
understanding two-way communication
between devices and and humans broadly
interpreted and and so that'll enable
all kinds of new applications in those
areas as well these problems have no
international boundaries you know we we
seek out and and have brought together
the best people in the world around this
problem whether they're in Canada
Germany the US or Japan and and that
really is is something that otherwise is
tough to get the attention of these
people and
for because of its reputation because of
its infrastructure is allowing us to do
that so that's a very exciting aspect
[Music]
you